when you guys are celebrating on the  floor you stand up you put the number 44  in the air how much is Wade Simms with  this team in these moments he's always  with us obviously we lost a brother but  we understand that he's always with us  this for our score was 44 at one point  and we all stopped in the huddle looked  up at the scoreboard and just said 44 in  the huddle we just knew we needed to get  this one for him and you got it you're a  Julian thank you thank you so much Jamie  Wade Sims was shot and killed their  teammate and brother in September this  season has been dedicated to him he wore  the number 44 and it's a number that  resonates within the LSU family LSU